there's really a sense of confusion here
as often is the case sadly when
incidents like this happened there's
lots of locals who have come out to try
and see what's going on a hugely heavy
police presence we've seen numerous
armed officers there are big fans of
police personnel there is definitely a
police helicopter circling above us as
well as you said reports had come in
sort of an hour or so ago that a person
a man had been shot and we now
understand that that man has died police
also saying that they believe a number
of people have been stabbed and that
they believe this incident is terror
related just before I came on at
torchie's sera I was looking at a video
that someone here had seen on Instagram
a little distressing we can't show it at
the moment on Sky News but it did appear
to show a very chaotic scene blood on
the pavement a number of people lying
there who appeared to have stabbed
wounds the video moves quite confusedly
up down the street seeing groups of
people crowding around a number of
different people who appeared to be
injured and then a bit further up the
high street behind me I don't know if
you can see beyond where our camera is
able to see there is a boots pharmacy
and it's understood that that is where
the man who was shot by police was shot
now there are a few things that are
interesting and and potentially a little
unusual about this and one that's worth
thinking about is the speed with which
police have designated this a terror
incident you may remember that horrible
attack on London Bridge just back in
December when that happened it did take
a number of hours for the police to
really get a sense of exactly what had
happened and before they were ready to
release officially to the public and to
the media that they believe this was
terror related the speed with which they
said it was this time is worth noting
also the fact that eyewitnesses have
said that the ambulances that arrived
the paramedics who came out of those
ambulances apparently were wearing body
armor that of course is very unusual
even in a city like London which is
sadly no stranger to terror instance at
all but those two things are interesting
certainly it's
much much too early to speculate about
exactly what happened here what the
police may or may not have known but
clearly there was some information they
had that led to those two things
happening potentially perhaps the
individual involved was maybe being
watch mate by police maybe he was under
surveillance maybe there was a sense
that what happened was not entirely
unexpected and police were allowed were
able to move very quickly indeed but of
course as I said that I thought his
speculation must stress that at the
moment we're really not clear what has
happened a video that we've seen does
appear to show people with relatively
serious injuries as I said it shows
blood splattered and on the High Street
sadly and other witnesses on Twitter
again it's very important to emphasize
that we can't verify this at the moment
but people saying that they saw somebody
with a puncture wound in their chest and
in their back as well unclear at the
moment whether that is the person who we
now understand to have died after being
shot by armed police unclear whether
that's other victims involved in this
incident but there's really a sense of
activity here as I said a lots of locals
have come out to see what's going on
this would normally be an incredibly
busy thoroughfare on a Sunday up on the
high street behind me if I just step out
the way so you can have a look a number
of shops there's a big a little up there
a Bhoots pharmacy a number of different
restaurants and fast food stands and
stalls at certainly the sort of place
that people would have been coming to
spend some time on Sunday and really a
sense of shock from people here that
this has happened at the high street is
now closed off